hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt hat es das stimmt doch irgendwas
nicht
ich glaube jetzt ist es ich stehe heute
in meiner küche und zwar hat die samira
morgen geburtstag sie wird 5 jahre alt
und sie ist totaler insofern also als
königin werden von dem film frozen
deswegen war es natürlich klar dass sich
der samira eine älter torte machen muss
und hat mich für eine elser torte mit
puppe entschieden das heißt für so eine
barbie torte der vorteil ist natürlich
man kann dem kind gleich noch eine
barbie schenken und hat praktisch um das
geburtstagsgeschenk
und außerdem ist diese torte wirklich
sehr einfach also auch wenn ihr wirklich
wenig zeit habt so eine torte zu packen
die torte ist wirklich in wenigen
stunden zubereitet ich habe für die
dekoration und für die zusammensetzung
der torte etwa vier stunden gebraucht
und habe am tag vorher bereits die
torten böden vorgebacken in etwa einer
halben stunde also insgesamt habt ihr
nicht mal fünf stunden arbeit und habe
dann am ende trotzdem eine richtig
schöne torte die ihr kind bestimmt
bezaubert und ich habe jetzt hier
drinnen einen leckeren schoko kuchen und
hab mich auch wirklich für einen
einfachen kuchen entschieden weil ich
einfach wollte das einfach der geschmack
im vordergrund steht und weil samira
eben schokolade über alles liebt hat
sehen sich auch in den schokoladenkuchen
gewünscht und ich habe deswegen auch auf
zu viel deko verzichtet weil ich einfach
nicht möchte dass später die kinder
einfach zu viel zucker eben auch
bekommen und daneben auch die torten
sehr lecker schmeckt und ich würde es
einfach mal sagen wir starten direkt für
mich zeigt euch was ihr dafür benötigen
ich zeige euch jetzt was ich alles
vorbereitet habe ich habe bereits meine
kuchen gebacken und zwar gestern
und zwar habe ich hier vier tortenböden
nach dem rezept meine saftigen
schokoladenkuchen und das rezept findet
ihr auf meinem blog
und hier habe ich noch meine schokolade
nascht dafür auch das rezept auf meinem
blog und außerdem brauche ich jedoch ein
bisschen saft und trinken da habe ich es
einfach den roten saft genommen und auf
den block stehen dann auch die genauen
mengen zu mengenangaben also wie viel
ich gemacht habe ungefährlich verwendet
habe und ja da können einfach mal
nachschauen
die tiger habe ich hier in 320 er
springt formen gebacken und diese
halbrunde form
die habe ich hier in dieser schlüssel
gebacken und zwar ist es eine edelstahl
rührschüssel und die habe ich vorher mit
back trend spray eingefettet und mit
mehl eier ausgestoppt wollte ich jetzt
schon wieder sagen mit mehl bestreut und
hab da einfach so etwa ein drittel der
form befüllt und da eben den teig drin
gefallen zuerst ließ sich jetzt die
kuchentheke aus der form die stand jetzt
einfach über nacht in so einer kuchen
glocke einfach hier in der küche wird
man natürlich auch in den kühlschrank
stellen
dann schneidet die daten bilden einmal
durch man kann nicht so schön befüllen
und das geht am besten mit orten säge
dem ich hier direkt im jackpot es hat 30
zentimeter im durchmesser und
staatsstreich ich jetzt ein bisschen
kanalstr
es war eher so an ein ende und jetzt
kann ich da den unteren boden schon mal
drauf setzen
und da wird jetzt mit etwas saft
getränkt der teig ist was schon saftig
genug aber ich finde da steht ja dann
noch über nach dem kühlschrank bis
morgen morgen ist nämlich so miraß
kinder geburtstagsparty und deswegen
möchte ich dass da noch etwas heftiger
wird und gefüllt wird er jetzt auch mit
etwas zarter kanals
da kommt jetzt der deckel drauf und so
verfahren stets weiter wie sich alle
böden aufgebraucht habe
bei dieser halbrunden form möchte ich
jetzt da oben diese werbung wegschneiden
damit die gleich glatt auf der torte
aufsitzt
und das setzt sich jetzt eher hier vorne
an
also nicht mittig sondern eher in die
richtung und die torte muss jetzt bevor
ich sehe zurechtschneiden kann erstmal
in den kühlschrank für etwa 20 minuten
damit die kasse etwas fest werden kann
und dann kann ich sie schon zurecht
schneiden
jetzt endlich die torte zurechtschneiden
dafür habe ich mir hier unten so ein
backblech hingelegt damit einfach nicht
alles auf die arbeitsfläche feld und das
kleid soll jetzt so natürlich wie
möglich aussehen das heißt ich muss
jetzt so eine rundliche form hinbekommen
und von der höhe her ist die torte jetzt
übrigens so also ich möchte später die
elfer rein stecken bis zur hüfte
das heißt ungefähr hier und da hat sie
eben unten noch ein bisschen platz
also ich musste dann ich bis komplett
unten rein stecken und von der höhe her
passt es doch auf jeden fall jetzt fangt
ihr einfach an und schreitet sie eben
schön in form
und hier an der stelle würde ich jetzt
noch etwas drauf streichen und dann
könnte einfach die kuchen reste benutzen
und es so ein bisschen auffüllen
und diese lücke hier und die fülle ich
jetzt auch einfach mit etwas kuchen tag
auf da habe ich ja noch den deckel den
ich vorhin abgeschnitten habe und kann
das hier einfach einstecken
jetzt habe ich meine gewünschte form
zurechtgeschnitten und jetzt muss ich
hier oben natürlich noch so ein loch ein
machen damit ich die puppe auch gleich
rein stecken kann
und ihr müsst euch jetzt so verstellt
also hier ist vorne und hinten ist
zuerst der popo und die puppe wird dann
eben ziemlich weit vorne rein gestellt
und jetzt muss ich mir hier so einem
loch zu sprechen schneiden entweder
mache das jetzt mit einem messer ich
habe jetzt hier von meinem ananas
schneider so ein langes teil das benutze
ich jetzt und steckt es jetzt einfach
mal da rein
ihr könnt auch ein ausstecher nehmen und
es entstanden und dann eben mit dem
messer schneiden
und weil die barbie-puppe eben ein
bisschen dicker ist muss ich noch mal
rein
jetzt möchte ich ja nicht die puppe
dreckig machen deswegen muss ich die
vorher eben etwas folie einwickeln aber
auch natürlich aus hygienischen gründen
damit ich da nicht die barbie in meinem
kuchen drin habe deswegen werden jetzt
die beine ein gewitter
jetzt steckt ich da mal die barbie
reihen
ich muss doch noch ein bisschen größer
machen
jetzt streicht sich die torte komplett
mit der kanal schein stellt sie gleich
noch kurz im kühlschrank und dann kommt
noch eine zweite schicht drauf und dann
kann ich schon mit sondern dekorieren
für den überzug nehme ich jetzt etwas
von dauer und ich muss mir jetzt die
farbe mischen weil ich ja nicht so hell
bleibt deswegen habe ich jetzt hier
etwas weiß und etwas blau und
wahrscheinlich noch etwas grün weil das
ist nämlich ganz hellblau das geht mehr
so ein bisschen dazu einen leichten
türkis stich deswegen nehme ich jetzt
erstmal das weiß die hände fertig mit
palm ihn ein als er mit kokosfett dann
klebt ist auch nicht und dann möchte ich
jetzt einfach ein bisschen blau und ein
bisschen grün ein
ich habe jetzt übrigens keinen grünen
ein geknetet weil das hellblau ganz
schön ist und auch wirklich gut zu der
elsa passt jetzt wird er von bauer
ausgerollt und zwar wolle er jetzt
ziemlich dünn aus weil ich einfach nicht
möchte dass del zurück dickler drauf
liegt und es geht am besten auf etwas
becker stärke
die torte bespricht jetzt mit etwas back
trance prey damit davon dann gut drauf
haftet aber ich mache das jetzt er
weiter oben weiter unten braucht es
nicht und jetzt gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten um von dort auf die torte
zu bekommen entweder macht man das bevor
man die puppe reinsteckt würde ich aber
nicht empfehlen da hat man nicht so
einen schönen übergang
oder man kann den fall dann jetzt
komplett über die puppe stecken dann
reiste halt oben und man muss es dann
später überdecken
oder so wie ich das jetzt mache ich
schneide jetzt einfach ein teil 1 und
der teil kommen dann nach hinten und ich
kann dann den später einfach überdecken
das heißt etwa hier und hier schneide
ich jetzt noch so ein loch für die
hälfte
hierhin und schneide ich es gerade weg
und der übergang das macht jetzt auch
nächstes überdecken wir nämlich stellt
jetzt lege ich unten bis kleid in falten
jetzt wird der rest einfach noch
weggeschnitten
da oben schneide ich jetzt noch die
überreste weg und da ist es jetzt nicht
schlimm wenn da von dort mit dem kleid
abschließt weil ich mich da nämlich
gleich noch so eine kleine broschüre
machen und so eine dekoration
ich habe jetzt hier etwas weißem von
dort ganz dünn ausgerollt und den stech
ich jetzt und aus und weil ich möchte
dass das ein bisschen an muster bekommt
standsicherheit noch schneeflocken ein
und zwar habe ich hier so schneeflocken
ausstecher und daher hat zum beispiel
auch so eine präge funktion und das kann
ich jetzt eben auch mit verwenden
dann schneide ich auch hier wieder ein
stück ein
und stelle ich in der mitte ein loch aus
und kann das an um die taille leben
das können da gerade mit bisschen wasser
oder etwas zucker kleber festkleben
die grundstruktur ist jetzt gemacht und
jetzt könnt ihr das kleid nach belieben
dekorieren
das mache ich jetzt auch und zwar nehme
ich dafür ein paar kristall pulver
farben
ich habe hier ein paar ein bisschen
streute corp perlen und sowjets der
zucker und ich nehmen natürlich von
dauer und ein paar ausstecher und ich
würde es einfach mal loslegen
ich möchte jetzt noch ein paar
buchstaben machen und habe jetzt hier
für etwas buyten passte mit blauem von
golfer mischt und den rolle ich jetzt
auf einen zentimeter aus das geht am
besten mit zu zwei hölzern und dann kann
ich direkt buchstaben ausstecher nehmen
und die buchstaben damit ausstechen
jetzt geht's weiter mit der torte ich
habe jetzt seht orte doch noch auf eine
größere tortenplatte gesetzt eine mit 40
cm durchmesser
denn ansonsten würden meine buchstaben
gar nicht drauf passen und ich habe die
zwei torten boards also die jackpots
einfach mit etwas doppelseitigem
klebeband verbunden
und jetzt möchte ich das skateboard
natürlich auch ein bisschen eindecken
damit es eben dazu passt und ich habe
mir hier so ein bisschen puderzucker mit
wasser vermischt ich habe auch nur so
eine ziemlich dicke konsistenz und das
streiche ich jetzt drauf und macht da
ebenso eine schneelandschaft hin
die elster torte ist fast fertig jetzt
fehlt nur noch eine schleppe also hier
vor allem kann man eben auch damit
diesen übergang verdecken und dafür habe
ich jetzt hier ein stück von doreen weiß
ganz dünn ausgerollt und wetten jetzt
mit dieser struktur rolle also
strukturieren
bei der torte ist jetzt fertig und neben
meiner tochter habe ich natürlich auch
eine echte eiskönigin und die samira die
torte jetzt noch nicht gesehen und ich
hoffe dir gefällt sie okay ich wollte
hier eigentlich erst morgen zeigen zu
ihrem geburtstag aber da ich die ja
sowieso bei unseren kühlschrank stelle
und samira selber an den kühlschrank
kommt hätte ich selbst nicht verstecken
können samira
hier stellt man bitteschön institut imk
mal was da steht und was ist das warum
glaubst du dir schmeckt dir und deinen
freunden
das freut mich aber und weil ja die
party diese elsa party auch vollkommen
abgerundet sein soll habe ich mich
natürlich auch ein bisschen eingedeckt
war bei unserem globus und habe auch so
noch ein paar sachen gefunden
auch von unserem shop zum beispiel ich
werde auf jeden fall noch rosen muffins
backen die darfst du dann auch mit zum
kindergarten nehmen
dann geht es natürlich auch wenn ihr
wollt so großen sticker für muffins dann
gibt's torten aufleger die kerzen finde
ich halt ganz süß da müssen wir schauen
wie wir die ebenso mit einbilden binden
und ich habe mir gedacht ich wohl auch
so kleine geschenk töten weil bei
kindergeburtstagen ist es ja auch so
dass man dann immer so gemacht und sie
dann ihren freundinnen etwas schenken
darf die muss ich heute auch noch
befüllen dann natürlich auch servierten
becher und teller und ich glaube dann
ist deine elsa party perfekt oder nein
ja du hast doch einen kuchen her was ist
heutzutage alles gibt also bei mir ist
das gab es alles was mir auch nicht als
ich wäre froh gewesen hatte
ausgeschickten abend haben sie wieder
reinlassen an und geburtstagen hier gab
es auch nicht aber ich persönlich keinen
spaß ich kann es vereins und also ich
finde es ja ich finde es schön wenn wir
doch so was machen kann und ich finde
also mir macht es selber natürlich auch
viel spaß und wenn ich da mehr damit
eine freude bereiten kann macht man umso
mehr spaß was ich übrigens noch erwähnen
wollte also das ist jetzt so eine
original elsa puppe seine elf habe
natürlich könnt ihr auch eine ganz
normale partie zum beispiel nehmen und
die dann mal die hat ja auch blonde
haare
und dann könnt ihr einfach das kleid
zaubern bei der puppe war das jetzt so
die hat ja schon dieses oberteil als ich
konnte ja nicht ganz ausziehen weil es
ja hier auch aus diesem plastik ist aber
ihr könnt zum beispiel wenn ihr sowas
macht und die barbie oben nackt ist dann
müsst ihr hier natürlich auch alles mit
fondant einkleiden einfach ganz dünn
ausrollen und eben den oberen teil auch
schön einkleiden das musste ich jetzt
halt hier nicht waren weil wie gesagt
die er da oben schon die kleidungsstücke
hat und wir stellen dir jetzt zurück in
den kühlschrank und weil ich immer
gefragt werde wie ich solche torten
transportiere
wir werden erst morgen den geburtstag
nicht zu hause feiern sondern in so
einem indoor-spielplatz werde ich die
torte natürlich auch dorthin
transportieren müssen mit dem auto und
ich zeige euch einfach ganz kurz was ich
dafür immer gerne verwende
normalerweise war es immer so dass sich
torten wäschekörbe transportiert habe
aber das problem da musste ich dann
immer handtücher und decken drunter
machen weil mein wäschekorb ebenso ein
bisschen abgewohnt war nicht ganz glatt
und es war halt immer so eine riskante
aktion im auto und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht komm ich hole jetzt endlich mal
so styropor transportboxen und habe
bereits auch welche seit letzter woche
und zwar sind es um verschiedene
bausteine
ich habe jetzt da unten eben den boden
da habe ich jetzt soll das silikon matte
darauf gelegt die habe ich ja immer so
zum aus 0
jetzt kann ich da die torte mit dem
skateboard draufsetzen und dann rutscht
die torte auch nicht hin und her also
wie ihr seht und jetzt könnt ihr je nach
höhe
da habe ich jetzt mittel entdecken aber
der wird ja jetzt nicht passen weil die
torte viel höher ist das heißt diesen
deckel kann ich jetzt nehmen wenn ich
eine flachere torte hat oder bei einer
höheren torte muss ich einfach noch so
zwischen das stück frei machen und dann
kommt noch der deckel drauf und dann
habt ihr eure taute schön verpackt und
im sommer könnt ihr dann eben auch
moment noch so und im sommer könnt ihr
dann eben auch so akku kühl pads mit
rein legen dann bleibt die torte eben
auch schön kalt also das finde ich ganz
praktisch und die gibt es einmal so in
ganz groß als wird die tortenplatte hat
er ja jetzt 40 cm im durchmesser also
richtig groß und die gibt es auch noch
in kleiner mit 29 cm
da könnt ihr dann torten bis 28 cm eben
reinsetzen und so wird die morgen
transportiert und dann kann eben auch
gar nichts passieren im auto rutschte
dann auch nicht hin und her die kommt
dann einfach in den kofferraum und dann
kommt sie eben auch schön heil an
ja das war eigentlich jetzt das video zu
der torte
ich hoffe ich konnte euch inspirieren
vielleicht wollt ihr die auch mal
nachmachen und schickt mir dann ein
bild auf facebook oder instagram und ich
bin schon gespannt wie ihr eure elsa tat
umsetzen werde
und ich freue mich schon aufs nächste
mal und wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken bis zum nächsten mal
ciao sage ich nicht wiederholt